la energía del futuro Made In Europa
esta giga fábrica de baterías para
vehículos eléctricos localizada en el
norte de Francia es la primera de cuatro
plantas para abastecer con baterías de
litio A toda Europa tiene una capacidad
de producción de baterías para 500.000
vehículos cada año Así Francia Busca
reducir su dependencia de Asia en el
competido sector energético
hoy es un gran día para las Industrias
en Francia hoy es un gran día para las
Industrias en Europa por primera vez
desde airbus Francia y Europa están
creando un nuevo sector Industrial el
sector de las baterías eléctricas
esta industria refleja la estrategia
francesa de atraer inversión al país con
incentivos gubernamentales pero también
está en línea con una nueva política
ambiental
un valle europeo para las baterías
eléctricas está emergiendo ante nuestros
ojos este proyecto es también la
expresión concreta de las acciones que
estamos tomando para combatir el
calentamiento global y reinventar
nuestros modos de producción y consumo
[Música]
la fábrica genera 10.000 nuevos empleos
el complejo será clave para cumplir la
meta del gobierno macron de producir 2
millones de vehículos eléctricos en
Francia para el año 2030